[music]
>> Brother Kumeruddin Abdullah.
I bring to you the greeting of peace.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullah
wabarakatuh. Wa alaykumu s-salam.
>> Respected Dr. Zakir Naik, brother
Kaleem, and brothers and sisters.
Alhamdulillah.
Was-salatu was-salamu ala rasulillah.
A'uzubillahiminashaitanirajim.
Wa qul ja al-haqqu wa zahaqal batil,
innal batila kana zahuqa.
Sadaqallah sadaqallahul azim.
The truth have comes
and the falsehood will perish.
Indeed, falsehood will perish.
Verily, Allah has spoken the truth.
Mankind today, even in the modern world,
they are worshipping the creation.
The only book,
the only book, brothers and sisters,
that emphasize worship of one true God
is Al-Qur'an ul-Karim.
Even though the Bible, in chapter 12,
verse 29, book of Mark,
it says,
"O children of Israel, our Lord God
one." And yet,
they worship three in one, the Father,
the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Even in the Hindu scripture, we mention
of the oneness of God and no
association, no images, and yet, man
is worshipping other than the true
creator. Only this book
not only talks about the oneness of God,
but also emphasize strictly without
compromise.
I invite
brothers,
especially our not yet Muslim friends,
to expound this book
and to see that touchstone of theology,
which the Christian have asked the
prophet, which the Jew have asked THE
PROPHET, THE PAGAN have asked the
prophet salallahu alayhi wasallam, "Man
huwa Allah?" Shiflana rabba. And yet,
Allah revealed the four beautiful verses
that which I accepted Islam. Bismillahir
rahmanir rahim. Qul huwa Allahu ahad.
Say, Allah is one and the only. Allahus
samad. Allah, the eternal absolute. Lam
yalid walam yulad. He begat not or is
begotten. He's not a physical father.
He's not A PHYSICAL SON. WALAM yakun
lahu kufuwan ahad. There's none like
unto him. Four verses, surat ul-Ikhlas,
chapter 112 of this book, 1 to 4.
Brothers and sisters, uh my beloved
non-Muslim friends at home and the
audience, please ponder this book
revealed to a man called Muhammad, and
latter prophet. And I'll give you a good
news before I leave the stage. Man qala,
"La ilaha illallah." Dakhala l-jannah.
Whoever say, "There's no god worthy of
worship."
He or she will enter paradise according
to the last messenger of God. Man huwa
Allah? Say, "Who is Allah?" Say there's
one God, you will attend paradise
forever, inshallah, and all your sins
will be forgiven. Wa akhiru da'wana wal
hamdulillahi rabbil alamin. As-salamu
alaykum warahmatullahu ta'ala
wabarakatuh. Wa alaykumu s-salam
warahmatullahu wabarakatuh.
Brother Firdaus Fong from Malaysia.
Bismillah. Alhamdulillah.
Rabbi shrahli sadri wa yassirli amri
wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli.
I would like to greet you with a
greeting of peace, greeting of Islam.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahu
wabarakatuh. Wa alaykumu s-salam
warahmatullahu wabarakatuh. Today, I
will be addressing a common questions
being asked when we are doing da'wah,
which is,
"If all the scriptures are being
revealed by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala,
then why we should follow the Qur'an?"
Now, here is the things. Let's look into
the Qur'an.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
Qur'an,
in chapter in surah Al-Hadid, chapter
57, verse number 25,
Allah says that he has sent his
messenger with clear evidence and with
scriptures.
And the scriptures that we know of that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala have revealed
to us is
Zabur
to David, Daud,
Torah, or what we known as Old
Testament, to Moses, Musa,
and then we have Injil to Isa alayhi
salam, Jesus Christ, and the last is
Qur'an to Prophet Muhammad salallahu
alayhi wasallam.
Now, let's look into this.
All the previous scriptures, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala never mentioned in
their scriptures that Allah will
preserve the book just like how Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala will preserve the
Qur'an.
Allah says in surah Al-Hijr, chapter 15,
verse number seven, that Allah is the
one who revealed this book and he will
protect it. He will preserve it.
And since Allah will preserve it and he
sent this Qur'an, this last scriptures,
to the last and final messenger, which
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions in
surah Al-Ahzab, chapter 33, verse number
40,
which he says that Prophet Muhammad is
the last prophet. And since he's the
last prophet, all the previous
scriptures has been sent to a particular
nations and a particular time.
Therefore, Allah says in surah
Al-Baqarah, chapter number two, verse
number 185, that this Qur'an was sent
was revealed as a huda lin nas, to
entire mankind. Now, let me give you an
example, my dear brother and sisters.
Just for example, in 2012, back home in
Malaysia, I'm from Malaysia,
that it is not compulsory for the
passenger to wear their seat belt.
But then, in 2014,
we have a new law stated that it is
compulsory for all passenger
to wear their seat belt. If they are not
wearing the seat belt, they will be
fined 300 ringgits.
300 ringgits. Just for example, if you
are being stopped by the police
and the police is asking you, "Why are
you not wearing your seat belt,
brother?"
And you are answering,
"Come on, sir. I'm following 2012 law."
What do you think that the policeman
will answer you?
The policeman will answer you that,
"Hey, brother, now is 2016. You follow
the latest law." And now, I would like
to conclude my talk with these words of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Let us see. In surah Al-Ma'idah, chapter
number five, verse 48, Allah says that,
"O Muhammad, we have sent to you a book,
a scripture
preceded the scriptures before this and
as a criterion for all of it." So, wa
akhiru da'wana, as-salamu alaykum
warahmatullahu wabarakatuh. Wa alaykumu
s-salam warahmatullahu wabarakatuh.
Brother Arshi Qureshi from India.
Alhamdulillah. Bismillah was-salatu
was-salam ala rasulillah. Fa
a'uzubillahiminashaitanirajim.
Bismillahirrahmanirrahim.
Ya ayyuhallazina amanuttaqullaha haqqa
tuqatihi wala tamutunna illa wa antum
muslimun.
As-salamu alaykum warahmatullahu
wabarakatuh.
Dear brothers and sisters, I welcome you
all. Uh I say sisters because the people
are watching. Dear brothers and sisters,
I welcome you all with the Islamic
greeting. May peace, mercy, and
blessings of be upon all of you.
My topic today is tawhid.
And it is very important to discuss
tawhid because as you know, tawhid means
to believe in oneness of Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala.
What to believe in the oneness of our
creator.
Without tawhid, tawhid being the first
pillar of Islam, and tawhid being the
first article of faith, which is a first
first article of iman,
uh there is no iman without tawhid. The
first article of iman is la ilaha
illallah Muhammadur rasulullah.
So, without tawhid, there is no iman.
Without iman, there is no Islam.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in
the Qur'an, in surah An-Nisa, chapter
number four, uh verse number 48, "Ya
verse number 48, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says,
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in surah
An-Nisa, chapter number four, verse
number 48, Inna allaha la yaghfiru an
yushraka bihi wa yaghfiru ma duna zalika
liman yasha. Wa man yushrik billahi
faqad iftara isman azima.
Allah says, "Allah will not forgive
shirk." Means associating partners with
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. But anything
less than that, Allah will forgive
whoever Allah wills for. And shirk is
the biggest of the sin.
So, dear brothers and sisters, I want
you to know three things very important
about tawhid. One is tawhid
al-rububiyyah, which is to maintain the
unity of the Lordship of Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala. Number two is tawhid al-asma
wa al-sifat, which is to maintain the
unity of the names and attributes of
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. And number
three is tawhid al-ibadah, which is to
maintain the unity of the worship of
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
And now I want to address our Christian
brothers and sisters all over the world,
especially uh people who read the Bible.
In Mark chapter 12 verse 29, a person
comes to Jesus and asked, "What's the
most important commandment?" And Jesus,
according to the Bible, replies, "Shema
Yisrael Adonai Eloheinu Adonai Echad."
Which means, "Hear, O Israel, the Lord
our God is one God." And the same thing
is repeated in Deuteronomy chapter 6
verse 4, which is "Shema Yisrael Adonai
Eloheinu Adonai Echad." "Hear, O Israel,
the Lord our God is one God." So, even
the Bible is talking about tawhid. So,
my dear brothers and sisters all over
the world, please stop worshiping the
creation and start worshiping the
creator alone. Do not associate partners
with Allah, and inshallah Allah will
guide you. So, ask for guidance. Stop
worshiping the creation, stop worshiping
the creator, and ask for guidance from
the creator that he may be pleased with
all of us and give us salvation. Wa
akhiru da'wana an alhamdulillah rabbil
alamin.
La
ilaha illallah.
Muhammadun
rasulullah.
Muhammadun [music]
Arju ridhaka ya Allah.
Anta al-rahimu ya Allah.
Habni ataka [music]
ya Allah. Anta al-karimu
Minka al-ata'u ya Allah.
Anta al-adhimu ya Allah. Fika al-raja'u
ya Allah. Anta al-halimu
al-rahmanu al-sattaru
maliku al-mulki al-ghaffaru al-wahhabu
al-mannanu al-muta'ali.
Al-rahmanu al-sattaru maliku al-mulki
al-ghaffaru al-wahhabu al-mannanu
al-muta'ali.
Allahu Allahu ya rabbi ya Allah.
Allahu ya rabbi ya
Allah.